I really didn't want to make the show
anymore we made the decision to keep
going without her but you know there was
definitely that moment where I said I
don't I don't know if this is a great
idea she was done she was done with the
show and we respected her wishes move on
and but yeah there was that moment where
we said to we do we still do the show
and clearly the show went on and did
continue to do well but was it ever the
same definitely not
for me personally out of me Adam
development I disagreed over which
ending should air okay or even he
pitches meeting the alternative ending
he didn't really have the beat laid out
as much as the one that aired and I
thought when I saw the one with Lauren
you know at that point everyone knew
Brody was dating are elevating it was so
untrue to me to what was what was really
going on it I think in terms of what
would remain in the zeitgeist of America
the the clever wink and the Hollywood
sign pulling away was the smarter ending
to go with you know that was my decision
to end it with the Hollywood I'm pulling
away